Dr Rafael milier is the 2020 Robert a
Burt presidential scholar in society and
Neuroscience in the center of Science
and society and a lecturer at the
philosophy department at Columbia
University his research focuses on
understanding the capacities and
limitations of deep artificial neural
networks as well as investigating the
nature and scope of self-representation
drawing on his expertise in philosophy
and cognitive science Dr miliere is
exploring the implications of recent
progress in deep learning for models of
human cognition as well as various
issues and ethics and Aesthetics he's
also investigating what underlies the
capacity to represent oneself as oneself
at the fundamental level in humans and
non-human animals
as well as the role that
self-representation plays in perception
action and memory in a world where
technology is rapidly advancing Dr
miliere is striving to gain a better
understanding of how artificial neural
networks work and establish fair and
meaningful comparisons between humans
and machines by doing so he hopes to
shed light on the implications of
artificial intelligence for our lives
imagine chatting with an artificial
intelligence about various topics and
feeling it was a real interaction what
would it mean to feel real
would passing the touring test suffice
or would you really like to know for
sure that an agent on the other side has
autonomy and feeling
Raphael asserted in his moving beyond
mimicry in artificial intelligence
article last year that what was once
science fiction is becoming reality
Raphael said that in June Google
engineer Blake lemioin told the
Washington Post that he was convinced
that Google ai's chatbot Lambda was
sentient
I know a person when I talk to it let me
on said therein lies the rub as
algorithms are getting increasingly good
at producing the kind of outputs that we
once thought were distinctly human it's
easy to get dazzled
like narcissus we get lost gazing at the
reflection even though it's not always
flattering Raphael said that we ought to
ask ourselves is there more to these
algorithms than mindless copy the answer
is not straightforward Raphael said that
some large pre-trained models are
trained exclusively on text in just a
few years these models have shown an
uncanny ability to write coherent
paragraphs explain jokes and even solve
math problems
he went on Emily Bender Tim Nick gabrue
and colleagues compared language models
to stochastic parrots alleging that they
haphazardly stitched together samples
from their training data parrots repeat
phrases without understanding what they
mean
Raphael said the ongoing debates about
whether large pre-trained models
understand text and images are
Complicated by the fact that scientists
and philosophers themselves disagree
about the nature of linguistic and
visual understanding in creatures like
us
many researchers have emphasized the
importance of grounding for
understanding but this term can
Encompass a number of different ideas
these might include having appropriate
connections between linguistic and
perceptual representations
anchoring these in the real world
through causal interactions and modeling
communicative intentions
now some have the intuition that true
understanding requires Consciousness
While others prefer to think of these
two as distinct issues
so it's no surprise that there's a
looming risk of researchers talking past
each other it's hard to deny that large
pre-trained models don't understand
language or the world in the same way
humans do we must understand the
difference as AI evangelists often
portray these models as having magical
abilities or being close to reaching
human level general intelligence this
misleads people and can lead to inflated
expectations
we must be mindful of the ethical
implications of deploying large
pre-trained models at scale and we must
remember that humans never stop learning
forming persistent goals or desires or
beliefs and memories all of which are
still largely missing in AI models have
you ever wondered how large pre-trained
models are able to produce such
impressive outputs many assume that
these models simply memorize sequences
from their training data but there's
ample evidence to suggest that this is
not the case in fact these models are
capable of producing novel sentences and
images that were never seen before
Raphael said that we can even call them
stochastic chameleons
as they're now able to seamlessly blend
in environments and adapt to the context
and tone and style of virtually any
prompt however this ability to mimic
also comes with risks these models are
prone to mimicking the worst aspects of
humanity including racist sexist and
hateful outputs Raphael said that they
can be excellent at bullshitting as they
have no intrinsic regard for truth or
falsity Raphael pointed out the elephant
in the room when it comes to mimicry he
said that it need not involve
intelligence or even agency the
specialized pigment containing cells
through which chameleons and cephalopods
blend in their environment may seem
clever but they don't require them to
intentionally imitate features of their
surroundings through careful analysis
the sophisticated eyes of the Cuttlefish
which capture subtle color shades of the
surroundings and reproduce them on the
cuttlefish's skin is a kind of
biological mimicry that can be seen as
solving a matching problem one that
involves sampling the right region of
the color space based on the context he
said that sufficiently advanced mimicry
is virtually indistinguishable from
intelligent Behavior and therein lies
the problem when scaled up models unlock
new capabilities combining novel
Concepts coherently explaining new jokes
to our satisfaction or working through a
math problem step by step to give the
correct solution
it's hard to resist the intuition that
there's something more than mindless
mimicry going on here
so what can we do we must be mindful of
the capacities the limitations and
potential risks of large pre-trained
models we must also be aware of the
power of artificial mimicry and how it
can be used for good and bad only then
can we ensure that these models are
being used responsibly and can continue
to benefit Society
enjoy the show Raphael it's an absolute
honor to have you on mlst I've been
following your work with great interest
I I love your Twitter uh posts honestly
welcome to mlst
um tell the audience a little bit about
yourself thank you it's great to be here
I've been listening to many episodes of
other years so it's great to be here
um
so
I'm interested broadly in how we can
gain a better understanding of uh deep
neural networks and how we can establish
meaningful but also Fair comparisons
between these networks and human
cognition in virus domains such as
language understanding reasoning
planning perception and so on and these
comparisons go both ways of course so
I'm interested in whether there are ways
in which student Works might be
human-like in terms of the kinds of
cognitive psychological capacities we
can ascribe to them
but you know also I'm interested in
whether we can uh take inspiration from
using work and deep learning to perhaps
update certain uh ideas in Collective
science about uh models of human
cognition
amazing okay and what's interesting to
me is I started out as a machine
learning person and um as as many of the
audience have have seen very very
quickly you go down the rabbit hole and
you start getting into cognitive science
and philosophy and there are so many
um really really deep questions actually
and there are so many intersectional
fields that that you know have
interesting
um answers to some of the questions that
we're going to be asking but why don't
we start the conversation by talking
about large language models now um I
guess I'm just going to hit you straight
with the killer question do you think
they are stochastic parrots or do you
think at this point it's a gross
trivialization to say so
so just for contextualization you're
referring to the stochastic Parts phrase
which uh came out of uh this this paper
by Emily bender and colleagues
um and to some extent elaborate some
ideas that were already expressed in a
previous paper by by bender and color
climbing towards nlu in which they
suggested that um
large language models cannot learn
anything about meaning uh and uh
essentially what they're doing is just
parroting uh the strings of texts in the
training data so the Hub hazardly
stitching together bits from the
training data as they put in the
stochastic Parts paper I do not think
that's a fair characterization of
language models as you as you probably
know
um
I think it's a tricky question because I
think I do get the impetus to resist
inflated claims about what language
models can do and I think it's important
to push back against some of the more
extravagant claims coming from uh AI
hype and uh and and various you know
sweeping statements about language
models being uh at the very edge of
artificial general human level
intelligence
and the like but I do think there is a
lot of fertile ground in between the
very inflationary claims about what
language models aren't can do like the
stochastic Powers claim and the more
inflationary
extravagant claims of like the one I
just mentioned and so that's kind of the
thread that runs through through my own
work is to try to explore that in
between I think uh reducing uh language
but all stochastic parity is problematic
because you can probably show that uh
what they do is not just memorize Asian
it's not just stitching together samples
from the training data
it's fairly actually very easy to show
that they can produce novel outputs
and I also think that it's not quite
right to uh
make a differential statements on the
basis of the claim that they only do an
extra prediction for example or people
say sometimes they just do it to
complete while it's true the the
learning objective is an expert
prediction right of course they learn
this uh joint statistical distribution
of the words but we shouldn't confuse
the learning objective with whatever
processing is happening inside the
network to achieve that objective
specifically the computations that are
induced during training in order to
reach that objective so what I'm more
interested in is
finding more about these computations
and thinking about how they might relate
to the kinds of computations we can
ascribe to humans or perhaps not Human
animals whether engage in various
cognitive capacities like reasoning or
planning or thinking or understanding
yeah it's so difficult to come at this
because I mean first of all I was
thinking to myself the other day that
it's almost like as a as a species we
weren't supposed to develop large
language models it's it's just insane
you know like we we've kind of by using
this technology that we barely
understand and nudging and working at
scale and using computation we we've
developed these artifacts that we don't
really understand and as you say they're
doing next token prediction but it could
be argued that they are learning some
kind of a world model and that's
something we can discuss we could
mechanistically look at the
architectural prize they're using these
um self-attention
um you know Transformers and and they
look at a certain type of permutation
invariance between Pairs of tokens and
we could look at the emerging
capabilities we could look at the lack
of capabilities we'll talk about
volition and fodas
um connectionism critique paper later
but you know you could look at
um uh the class of of language model
from a Chomsky point of view there's so
many different positives and negatives
but we are where we are they are
incredible and they do things that are
very surprising
yes I think I think they definitely do
things that are very surprising and
sometimes we get used to that but if we
look back 10 years ago uh no one would
have expected that just uh training a
statistical model on Expert prediction
and large corporates would would achieve
this kind of capability and again I
think it's important to
um
you know take a step back from just
considering the learning objective and
the architecture itself and be more
open-minded about what might emerge from
the repertoire of computations induced
during training which is what a lot of
researchers do they are trying to find
out with mechanistic interpretability to
work for example you can train models
and train to reverse engineer what's
happening inside them but just knowing
everything you can know about the
architecture of the model Transformer
and uh and and
pre before it's trained and and and the
learning objective is not going to tell
you uh what kind of capacity you can
ascribe to a trend model I think that's
the important point
interesting I mean there's another few
things that we'll get to later in the
conversation but for example the symbol
grounding problem for example the lack
of analogy uh making
um and actually if you look at many
disciplines and philosophy like
structuralism
um there are so many I guess what I'm
saying is that meaning is about
recognizing these sounds that are not
being made in the music right there's
there's the missing information problem
and what we do as humans is we kind of
create information to fill in the gaps
where the music isn't playing and it
feels like language models don't do that
yes there are a lot of things to be said
about meaning and language models uh to
be clear just to qualify my favorite
statements I'm not saying that there is
nothing we can
infer from considerations of the
architecture of the models and their
learning objective about what kinds of
capacities they may in principle acquire
uh obviously a language model that is
trained on text only
will never acquire perceptual capacity
strictly speaking right so there are
things like that that we can obviously
infer from from this kind of
consideration what I'm talking about is
more uh the the
most uh
maybe less rigorously defined and and
and uh more contentious uh
psychological capacities or human like
cognitive capacities that are uh in
debate when it comes to language models
such as capacity to do some forms of
reasoning uh or indeed capacity to
understand language to some extent and
that's that's where the meaning question
comes in and I have a lot of thoughts
about this but
um
I think yes it's it's important uh once
we've established that these models are
trained on text only for the ones that
are just Auto aggressive uh Transformers
tendon text
we can rule out certain capacities uh
that by definition they cannot acquire
but that still lives open a lot of room
for discussion uh about what they might
be doing in order to achieve next word
prediction
yeah I'm interested to know how much of
a receding Horizon you think it is I
mean I spoke to Mary Shanahan recently
and he had he had a paper about language
models and he was quite clear that they
do have emergent reasoning and we can
talk about whether it is still reasoning
if you have to kind of create the prompt
yourself to tell it how to reason
um but he was quite clear that I mean
like so he he invoked Dennis intentional
stance for example and we'll talk about
theory of mind but I think the theory of
mind is is somewhere halfway on the
horizon where we possibly could think of
language models as being you know agents
who understand the beliefs and states of
Mind of of others but John cell would
say that this kind of phenomenal
experience or subjective experience is
something completely divorced from the
form of language
yes
um I think it's important to keep
certain questions separate one of which
is uh can we scribe any Consciousness to
large language models uh this is a very
Infamous question that uh has come into
the public
Consciousness uh number intended
recently with the Lambda uh story of
black Lemoyne but has also attracted
some interest from researchers like
David Chalmers among others
that's a question that
um I think it's very hard to settle for
various reasons uh and I'm happy to talk
a little bit about that but I think it
comes apart from questions about whether
language models
I I'm I'm reluctant to use the term
understand because it also comes bundled
up with a lot of connotations including
the assumption that to understand
language one might need to be conscious
which was Charles assumption uh so I'm
I'm trying to resist that assumption and
that's why I prefer to talk about
semantic competence in language models
for example so uh how much can uh can
they induce about the semantics of words
and sentences uh during training uh
regardless of what we think about
whether they are conscious for the
record I don't think we can ascribe
meaningfully conscious experience
through language models but uh the full
story would be that uh it's impossible
to know for sure uh it's just a very
very strong uh implausibility claim
could you introduce semantic competence
and and also um I know you're reticent
to do this but I'm I'm really fascinated
by
um the space of possible minds and the
space of possible understandings so we
can accept that there are different
minds and different forms of
understanding and Melanie Mitchell put a
paper out recently talking about
different modes of understanding and
then some modes are more compatible with
humans than others so even if it is a
legitimate mode of understanding is it a
useful mode of understanding if it's
different to us and therefore unreliable
yeah so the term understanding I think
is is uh somewhat unhelpful in some
contexts unlike unless we make these
distinctions because
as I said first of all it tends to to
bundle up several things like symmetic
competence and Consciousness but also it
tends to apply to different domains so
we can talk about understanding for uh
semantic competence when it comes to
link language and we can also talk about
visual understanding understanding the
scene through perceptual capacities uh
and we can talk about understanding also
in more abstract ways that might be uh
also non-linguistics perhaps uh so uh
what might talk about having an
understanding of I don't know a certain
feeling or something like that
um
what about semantic competence
specifically uh I think it's also
helpful to break it apart uh as a
concept
um so so generally when you think of of
linguistic competence that refers to uh
the kinds of capacities that a language
user has uh to uh be a competent user of
that language to make to make use of
that language uh in a way that that
satisfies certain standards of use and
that involves uh
syntactic competence so uh certain uh
ability to
parse and apply uh
grammatical uh rules or the the
syntactic structures that are found in a
given language
um and here there would be various also
further uh subtle distinctions about
competence in the champion sense which
is something a little bit more uh even
abstract that uh than competence in any
given particular language but but I'll
leave that aside uh
um and uh and so the synthetic
combination there is semantic
competencies pertains to uh the the
capacity to grasp the meaning of
linguistic expressions and symmetic
competence comes apart uh uh into
um lexical competence about the capacity
to press the meaning of words and
structural or compositional competence
which refers to the capacity to
understand the meaning of uh or grasp
the meaning of complex Expressions so uh
sentences and and
paragraphs and so on and obviously there
is a there is a lot of overlap between
syntactic competence and structural
semantic competence because in order to
course the meaning of complex
Expressions you need to be able to
parse the syntactic structure of such
Expressions but if you focus on word
meanings for say for a second because
that's perhaps the
the case that's been most discussed when
it comes to understanding and language
models
there is one notion of lexical
semantic competence which appeals to the
capacity to
rasp the reference of words in the world
right which is the notion that someone
like Emily bender and her co-authors in
the climbing towards the natural
language understanding paper or the
stochastic Parts paper appeal to so this
is reflected in my ability to for
example name objects in the world so I
can point to this and say this is a
smartphone I can come to this and so
this is an octopus
um it's I'm also capable of responding
to instructions you gave me in natural
language to perform actions in the world
so I can you can tell me go and fetch uh
the red pen on the table I can do that
um so that's this referential notion of
lexical semantic competence there is
another notion which is the inferential
notion of symmetic competence which
pertains to our capacities to relate
words with each other for example
through definitions or through analogies
um and uh and and through Vice other
ways in which we're able to form uh
meaningful connections between words and
once we make that kind of Distinction uh
things get a little bit clearer when we
when it comes discussions of some of the
competence again as a substitute for
understanding generally speaking in uh
AI models generally So In classical
symbolic models think of shrdlu from
terabinograd and of the 60s early 70s
it's a system that could receive natural
language instructions
uh and could parse these natural
language strings and then in response to
them perform operations in a virtual
world called the blocks world where they
were bodies geometrical shapes like uh
blocks and try and triangles pyramids
and so on that had different colors and
locations and so uh chrw was a system
that was capable to in response to this
to the sequence pick up the red block
and place it on top of the Blue Block
for example uh uh could could pass these
instructions and perform these actions
in the in the virtual environments so
you could say that a system like this
um
in some sense has a form of referential
lexical symmetic competence because it
is capable to
map the
symbols that are given in the in the in
the linguistic input onto objects uh not
in the real world but a virtual world in
that case except that the the semantics
here is is totally baked in by
programmers so it's not induced in any
way from experience in this world from
interacting with this world is just
hard-coded into the program but
nonetheless it is a form of referential
competence it's able to to do things
with language in that world or to
respond to language in that virtual
world and you could think of language
models as uh leaning towards having the
the the opposite uh like kansa kind of
of of competence uh so chrwellu has this
kind of reference with somebody
competence it has little to no
inferential semantic competence because
it's not really uh able to uh do things
like uh reasoning about analogies it's
it's able to do limited inferences uh
from uh language to language based on
baked in rules but uh that's uh that
that's very limited by contrast language
models because they're trained on these
testicle learning objective uh and
essentially they learn uh to uh they
learn complex patterns of core current
statistics in language uh not only just
first order statistics corporate
statistics like backgrounds and grams
but also uh sacred Order corporate
statistics like which words tend to
occur in the same context perhaps apple
and and pair tend to both appear in
their near pi and so on and even higher
order patterns of curriculum statistics
that become very hard for us to rub our
head around but uh map onto very complex
uh dependencies between words that we
don't even think about when we use
language and that enables enables these
models to
um
to induce a lot of uh information about
how words relate to each other within
language uh based on their use uh in uh
various ways and we know that of course
they do this by mapping words and two
vectors in very high dimensional Vector
spaces uh where uh the the the the
proximity of these vectors can be
adjusted during training to reflect uh
these along along these many many
different dimensions that are not human
interpretable to reflect uh these uh
patterns of statistical relationship
between words so we could say that
language models have a really
significant degree of inferential uh
lexical semantic competence and by
contrast the the charge that is uh put
forward against these models by people
like Community Bender is that they have
a very limited perhaps not not any form
of referential uh lexical semantic
competence I would perhaps also push
back against that second claim to some
extent but but I think the gist of this
characterization is is correct
yeah and you've used slightly different
language to help I would have described
that but I completely agree so this this
second mode this referential
um ability and I would say that I mean
abstractions are a meta relation between
data not only words because there are so
many things we need to to frame up here
because if it's only words they're not
subscribing to foda's view of the
language of thought which is that you
know the words are the first class
citizen of thoughts and I don't think
you believe that we have visual
understanding we have different modes of
understanding some some of which are not
verbalizable and then there's all of the
different forms of grounding now um John
so I really like the way he he framed
this up he said that there's
um ontologically subjective and
objective and epistemically
um objective and subjective and this
kind of speaks to some of the different
modalities of of mapping and then
there's the symbol grounding problem
which sort of leads to how these um
these symbols are grounded to things in
physical reality and abstractions of
course by definition aren't grounded to
anything in physical reality and then
some things are grounded to things in
Social reality or in some you know kind
of emergent uh reality and then we have
pragmatics as well which is this kind of
motion that there might be
um things outside of everything we just
spoke about or there might be some kind
of social consensus or you know
sophisticated game of Charades around
how we um derive meaning based on on on
on its use so you can see this is a very
very complex nebulous topic to speak to
yes it's definitely a very uh uh complex
question partially because also it's
it's you know these these systems
language models are still very new we
don't uh yet fully understand them and
and mapping uh some old uh discussions
about meaning onto the systems is not
always uh straightforward but there is
this thread that runs you know from
um the late Wittgenstein to uh
structural Linguistics in 1950s uh with
a workout Jr for example you shall know
a word by the company it keeps so this
idea that came to be known as
distribution of the distribution of a
hypothesis and then gave rise to
distributional semantics and
distribution distributional semantics
models all the way to modern language
models that's the thread that focuses on
uh the inferential side of semantics the
the distribution of relationship between
words as being a key aspect of of uh the
meaning of words uh uh essentially the
idea being that uh the um
by looking at the context in which a
word appears in a sufficiently large
corpora you should be able to induce uh
what that word means uh in in this
context
okay but to to pick up on that so why
didn't we bring in Melanie Mitchell has
written a lot about forming analogies
and and she's very careful to use the
word forming because large language
models um the mimicry is so impressive
that you would be forgiven for thinking
that they already have the ability to
use analogies and that's because they've
kind of they're a materialized snapshot
of the result of the language game and
the result of all of this you know
Evolution and maturation in society in
our use of language and so on but but
they can't form analogies and she used
an example of on top of as being a great
analogy so
um she's on top of her game or he's on
top of the television and this is a
great example of it's not in the data
right it's the missing information
problem so you need to have an
architecture that I don't know whether
it needs to and by the way this is one
of the fundamental problems in AI which
is that do you have a blank slate and do
you let intelligence emerge or do you
kind of seed it with base cognitive
priors and you know of which all of your
abstractions and and various cognitive
capabilities are deducible from those
priors through some kind of search or
creative process and this is this is the
problem because we know that large
language models are I don't want to use
the word interpolators but they are
basically ways of compressing
decomposition you know decomposing
representing what already exists and we
know that forming analogies is a kind of
like it's a creative process you're
creating something that doesn't already
exist
yeah I think that touches in a really
deep uh a set of questions about what
language models are really doing that is
perhaps a bit more nuanced than just the
the debut or we are just doing next word
prediction because against again I think
uh in the process of index for
prediction uh as well as the two
virtually any linguistic context you
have to end up acquiring certain
sophisticated capacities
um but I think the question here is are
there just
um you mentioned interpolation uh there
is this this I remember this whole
discussion about whether interpolation
in high enough uh in a highly F
dimensional space is equivalent to some
kind of extrapolation there's this paper
by again the queen about this uh I know
I know I know Frances sholay has a very
different view on this
um and just that makes nothing it
relates to this discussion about
compression in language models so there
was this recent teaching uh article I
think in the New York Times
um that uh talked about compression uh
uh in relation to language models and uh
you know I mean it was it's brilliantly
written as always with their Chang uh
but uh I had some slight concerns about
the way in which the analogy is set up
in that particular piece of course it's
a general organism it's not a research
paper but
um he's trying to explain what chat
Deputy does by saying it's essentially
like a blurry jpeg of the web uh so it's
training of this data script from the
web
and essentially uh uh what it's doing is
uh it's just uh um compressing that
information
in a way that is lossy so it's a form of
velocity compression uh in in his in his
in his View and then uh just uh
regurgitating the degraded uh version of
of that database and that that Losi
compression that he compares to
interpolation in Pixar space uh when you
do say jpeg decompression
um
so I think there are some parts of these
analogies that are right and some others
that are wrong so it's pumping some good
inductions and some unhelpful intuitions
I think
um so there is obviously a very
interesting and deep analogy a
relationship between compression and
statistical language modeling
um and uh it is true that in the process
of do you know learning from this next
word prediction objective uh the model
will end up uh um inducing uh some
structure in the data that affords uh
some some capacity to compress the
information uh containing the data
including things like syntactic rules
for example like grammatical rules or
things
um
I don't think however that generation
with uh so inference with the language
model is is
anything like decompression lossy
decompression within the image
decompression for example
um when you're sampling from a language
model you're not just trying to
regurgitate the training data but in a
lossy manner right uh there is
memorization that does happen uh but
that's that's not the only thing that
language models are doing that relates
again to the idea that are they just
stochastic Powers so are they just
regurgitating uh haphazardly uh
stitching together
bits and pieces from the training data I
don't think they are and I think it's
it's I mean that there's a lot of
research on memorization that shows that
they are not just doing memorization if
your goal was just to to memorize the
training data uh then uh you know the
most efficient way to do this is just to
uh to take the training data and
directly uh uh do some kind of uh
similarity search and regurgitated
pieces from the training data and
they're doing something different
um I I recently listen to this uh
interesting talk by Jack Griffin AI
about compression
um that he he touches the detection
piece but he has this interesting idea
that
um you can actually think up like large
language models in an idealized scenario
as uh perfect lossless uh compressors
rather than no C compressors uh and the
idea here is that
um the compression
that is that is happening uh is very
much related to the capacity of language
business to generalize instead of just
memorizing
um because in order to learn to compress
the training data as efficiently as
possible uh these models need to learn
the patterns the generative patterns uh
uh that underlie that
training data which enable them these
models to generalize to uh out of the
distribution
generative tasks so I think there is a
meaningful relationship between
compression and language models and I
think it's very intriguing to think of
generalization and lossless compression
as being related and and jackpot does
this in the context of a discussion of
minimum description then uh and
information theory that that is very
interesting but I think the lossy
compression analogy with the blurry jpeg
isn't helpful because again it harks
back to this idea that language models
are only memorizing and are they are
incapable of generalizing
I wouldn't say they're incapable of
generalizing I mean first of all on your
point on generalization the problem with
machine learning is it kind of does
everything it learns a spectrum of
correlations and the correlations we
want are the Ood ones but um most of
them unfortunately are kind of overfit
to the sample that we train on and
there's there's an interesting Spectrum
I've seen it visualized in a couple of
papers but um
yeah so the the problem is we're talking
about something which is just
um completely unintelligible you started
off by speaking about interpolation and
interpolation is something that only
makes sense in about two or three
dimensions actually if you look at
euclidean spaces in general
um three four five Dimensions the
behavior changes dramatically who have
the cursive dimensionality and um
actually interpolation is a concept that
doesn't really exist in high Dimensions
it's a very vague concept and no one has
a good definition for it and we've
spoken about this great length on
several mlst episodes and it's the same
thing with compression uh because you
know Walid subur says to me the reason
why
um large language models are not nlu is
because they're compression algorithms
and nlu is inherently a form of
decompression it's disambiguating the
you know the the meaning out of all of
the possible meanings but I would argue
again that when you have these very
large scale models look at stable
diffusion right look at it it's cutting
and gluing and people say oh no the Deep
learning model it's it's learning the
intrinsic manifold of the data no it's
not it's approximating it to a certain
extent these models are just cutting and
gluing and they're learning the surface
statistics of billions of tokens and
it's something which is just beyond our
comprehension so it's so difficult for
us to really you know speak
authoritatively about it I think there
is a there is a lot of
um room for
uh Middle Ground views between the idea
that uh language models are
perfectly uh inducing you know the
underlying manifold of of uh the
training data and the idea that just
cutting and gluing right and again
that's that's generally I'm what I try
to do yeah when I approach this topics
is articulate this middle ground because
people tend to to Really much very much
polarize uh get polarized on these on on
on Extreme to extremes of the of the
spectrum
um so look stable diffusion for example
you can probably use it for uh velocity
compression that's true right so you can
you either there was this blog post that
was doing this so you can uh just uh use
the model weights as a way to perform
those decompression in a way that's
significantly more efficient than say
jpeg or even other person formats but of
course you will get okay the occasional
hallucination or uh it's it's the it's
it's it's it can be a very lossy uh in
the way the the image is decompressed
but you can do that uh but I don't think
any instance of running inference on
stable diffusion if you want to take
that example is an instance of that so
there's only a very
specific set of cases in which you're
explicitly doing something like that
um and you might obviously have some
generations from the model that are very
very similar to samples from the
training data
but you can also do some uh
generate some things that uh seem to
generalize non-trivially from what's
present in the training data so a a very
minimal basic example that I felt around
at the beginning when Delhi 2 came out
was uh with uh conceptual combinations
so combining certain Concepts uh I mean
everyone knows by now the avocado chair
but the avocado chair is not a good
example because presumably uh I mean
there might be some examples of avocado
chairs in the training data I mean it's
it's not I actually haven't double
checked but I'm sure some designers
somewhere have actually designed some
chairs looking like avocados and so
um this particular combination probably
was somewhere in there but you can think
of more random combinations uh that and
people have been generally generating
some some wild images with these models
um it's very impossible to think that
all of these possible combinations that
combine visual concepts that would
really never be combined in the training
data uh can be accounted for in terms of
just gluing and stitching I mean the
gluing and stitching the way in which
some people who are pushing back against
air for example uh for copyrights uh
concerns
the way in which reports and people
think about this is literally just you
know doing some kind of collage of of
you know taking a face from from from
that bit of the training sample and body
from that bit and the background
um
and of course that's not uh in the vast
majority of cases what's happening uh I
mean it's not it's definitely not
literally what's happening but but it's
also not what the uh you you you will
rarely find images that uh can neatly
map like this onto bits and pieces from
different training samples uh what you
might find instead in is is images that
uh uh uh seem to have induced properties
from different training samples the
style of a of some some parts of the
search running training data and uh the
the shape of an object from a different
sample from the training data but it's
that's not just gluing and stitching in
a in a trivial sense right so that's
already something more
well I mean I maybe I should clarify a
little bit I don't have any problem with
cutting and gluing
um I don't think saying that stable
diffusion is cutting and gluing is in
any way an indictment of stable
diffusion the reason it doesn't
understand it's got nothing to do with
it cutting and gluing the reason it
doesn't understand as you said earlier
is it doesn't have these meta relations
between Concepts that don't exist in the
data if it had that information and it
cut in glue then it would work as far as
I'm concerned right but but I I still
don't I'm not sure the cut and glue
analogies is the right one because it
evokes this college is that uh
are not quite how uh uh it seems that
these models actually work perhaps in a
linguistic case it's it's it's more
clear-cuts because you can actually test
say compositional generalization we have
some synthetic uh data sets that have
been used like scan and others cogs so
the the Italians has done all the work
on this
um so you have a synthetic data set that
are designed in such a way that the only
way for a model to perform well is to
generalize completionally from uh the
trend set to the test set because the
problem when you assess the capacities
uh language models just to international
data or natural language data like this
massive cobra that's a big big model of
the trend of all of common crawl and
Wikipedia and thousands of books is that
basically virtually any syntactic
construction will appear in the training
data and therefore it's hard to know
whether uh when it's you know generating
perfectly grammatical sentences and uh
uh with virtually any kind of synthetic
construction it's not doing anything
more than as you say uh cutting or
gluing in some in some sense
um
but if you look at performance on these
compositional generalization data sets
um the picture that emerges is a bit
more uh nuanced so vanilla Transformers
analystms for that matter uh
don't do perfectly uh the uh fall short
of
human
performance on most of these benchmarks
but there have been a lot of work to try
to
um introduce some tweaks to the vanilla
Transformer architecture uh maybe change
the type of position or encoding uh or
into this other uh other tweaks that
seem to significantly strengthen their
capacity to generalize completely from
the test set to the trendset to the test
set
um so that's the case where
you know if the model is generalizing
completionally which is
provable by just looking at the
performance on the test set
I don't think it's meaningful to to to
characterize it as just you know uh
gluing cutting and gluing
yeah no I I really don't I don't think
of that as being a pejorative statement
and and so much of this is about what's
intelligible to us I think that there
are many different paths to intelligence
and
um the paths that can be traversed
through a large language model are
defined by the way we optimize them and
and the architectural prize and so on
and if the prize do cutting and gluing
and there is a path to intelligence
reversible through that framework then
as far as I'm concerned I mean we'll get
to what is intelligence later because so
many of the conceptions are based on
Behavior you know if it quacks like a
duck then it's a duck and I hate that
but unfortunately it's undeniable
because there are so many different ways
of producing intelligence and if you say
that you need this particular mechanism
to produce intelligence then you know
that's just not a very strong argument
but we'll get to that um in in a minute
um maybe we should move to just
compositionality in in general
um so this is kind of like I I think of
this as being very related to the idea
of systematicity that was
um you know coined by foda and pollution
in their 9 1988 connectionism critique
and they also spoke about productivity
but
um maybe you could just kind of like
speak for a minute just kind of
introducing what you know what they what
they were saying about systematicity
yeah so so uh Fodor and pollution uh and
and uh other philosophers at the time
um pointed out that
um
our capacity to uh produce linguistic
expression is uh regimented by a certain
um
a phenomena such as uh the fact that
we are able in principle to
produce Expressions uh of indefinite
length or indefinitely a novel and
complex Expressions just by recursion
for example that's the productivity of
language so I can say
um
you know John's father likes apples uh
and I can say uh John's father's
father's father like like apples and and
then just you know uh uh by by
recursion uh create uh
more and more complex senses of that
type and infinitium if I weren't limited
by other contingent limitations such as
uh you know working memory limitations
and so on uh so that's the productivity
of language and and there is this other
phenomena that was pointed out discussed
at the time uh heavily which is the
systematicity
of language namely uh that uh if one is
able to to understand the sentence uh
John loves Murray uh it seems that we
should also be able to understand the
sentence Mary loves John so there are
this um
this systematic connections between uh
the kinds of of
linguistic expressions and and basic
structure we're able to pass
that also relates to the kinds of
inferences we're able to make
um based on linguistic inputs
so that's a phenomenon that we find in
language and that's a phenomenon that
people like photo or uh uh have argued
is also characteristic of thought so a
thought is also productive in the same
way I can think of indefinitely many uh
thoughts uh uh in the same way so it's
productive it's also systematic because
it also has this
systematic
connections that govern the way in which
occupancy to think certain thoughts
photo of course he pointed out that
language you know has productivity and
systematicity and um it's completely
natural to make the leap and say well
um language is the system of thought I'm
not so sure that the world we live in is
systematic and that's why I'm skeptical
that you can take something like alphago
and apply it in the real world and and
would it be systematic in in the same
way but the reason why this is
interesting to bring in after what we
were just speaking about previously is
the whole point of of that connectionism
critique paper is to talk about a
capability which is not achievable with
connectionist or with neural network
models and and you were just saying that
you you
um produced this um uh this conceptual
combinations task on on big bench and it
appeared to be it's a receding Horizon
but it appeared to be working reasonably
well and there's two explanations here I
mean like first of all there's the
shortcut rule you know we were just
talking about the spectrum of
correlations and most of them are
spurious most of them aren't the ones
that we want so it could have been
cheating
um or it could have been the fact that
it is actually possible to achieve these
capabilities with these um you know
neural network models but the whole
point of that paper was to show that
it's not it's theoretically impossible
to do this kind of you know um
systematicity and that kind of
generalization with deep learning models
so
which is it yeah so there's a lot here I
think to unpack so the first thing I
would say is that the language of third
hypothesis comes apart from the claim
that uh we think in language uh or uh
even that we need language uh to think
so it's more of a claim about the the
structure uh of cognition uh in terms of
uh the format of the representations
that are manipulated when we think and
the way in which this representations
are manipulated uh so here is how we
move from productivity and systematicity
to that uh the idea is that for
a thinker to think in ways that are
systematic and productive
um that thinker must be able to
um uh
parse and and process representations uh
compositionally uh meaning that it must
be able to so it's a composition 18
language is is the the phenomenon uh uh
or the principle is it's this this
canonical formulation from Barbara party
in linguistics uh the idea that
um the meaning of complex Expressions is
determined by the meaning of uh the
elements of that expression so for
example the words that make up that
expression the expression together with
uh the syntactic structure uh of that
expression so the way in which these
words are combined in the expression
um and uh we could talk about
compositioning for for hours in the
loosen domain that reason to think that
lateral language is not strictly
compositional in that sense because the
obvious phenomena like idioms and others
uh you know extra linguistic influences
on on meaning that uh seem to to and
tell that natural language is strictly
compositional but photo argued that
thoughts must be uh compositional as
well uh meaning that you must have this
constituent structure where Atomic
representations uh are combined uh
according to us to certain a certain
syntax uh into complex representations
as such that uh when uh we think of
complexity potential to say I think of
John loves Murray I am co-tokening
Atomic representations that like verbs
nation of John uh within that complex
um uh representation uh and therefore it
has this the discrete constituent
structure it is made up of these more
Atomic representations so this is easy
to account for in a classical symbolic
system like the good old-fashioned AI
systems in which essentially that's what
you have you have symbolic uh you have
Atomic symbols that can be combined into
a complex symbolic representations
according to uh that has certain syntax
uh and and the the symbols are arbitrary
they have arbitrary shapes but they're
uh they can receive uh semantic
interpretation so he made an empirical
claim which is that connection is
systems artificial neural networks
are not uh capable in principle of
achieving the kind of compositional
behavior we see in humans
including say systematicity and
productivity
um
unless they are literally implementing a
classical architecture so unless they
are just uh you know unimplemented is
what at the time some people call the
implementational connectionism unless
they're literally implementing something
like a classical architecture with this
constituent structure
um yeah so that's the empirical claim I
would argue that this empirical claim is
is more or less at this point uh this
proven I think that the the the the
recent progress of deep learning uh has
more or less shown that you can read I
mean I was just talking about this this
compositional generalizations benchmarks
it the results are still a still a bit
of a mixed bag depending on how
um
what you think of these tricks on
Transformers that achieve Creator uh
generalization but still uh
it when looking at the you know the fact
that language models can can generate
perfectly grammatical sentences uh uh
um of of virtually any kind uh uh this
puts a lot of pressure on this critical
plane and then there is a further claim
which is that
um
the uh um on the right there's a really
to claim that the only way to achieve
the kind of compositional behavior you
see in in humans uh is to have that kind
of discrete composition constituent
structure and that the ways to try to
get compositionality out of a
non-implementational connection system
uh are just to fail so that's a claim
that's nursing to explore in light of uh
the non-classical form of
compositionality I think one finds in
modern deep learning system and then he
made a claim about another Claim about
the way in which
um
compositional performance uh is uh the
the the the mechanisms that supported in
humans in human cognition arguing that
uh that is supported by this kind of
language of thought with the with this
kind of discrete constituent structure
um I think that claim is not
directly
uh
have threatened by the recent progress
uh language models because it took them
about human condition and just because
language models can achieve something in
one way doesn't mean that humans achieve
it in the same way so uh it takes a
little bit more work to suggest that
this is not what's going on in the human
case either and I think looking at
deploying models can help sharpen uh
discussions about this specific
environment cognition but now I want to
come to the to the the big bench test
that you mentioned which is I
collaborated with some colleagues so big
bench is this massive collaborative
Benchmark that was spearheaded by people
like Google AI and what was interesting
is that they explicitly appealed to
people working other disciplines
including linguists psychologists and
philosophers to contribute specific
tasks to this Benchmark and it's made up
of a huge amount of tasks over 100 tasks
I think so with some colleagues we
designed a task that was designed to see
whether language models can pass novel
conceptual combination so we took
inspiration here from the work of
Gregory Murphy uh and Brendan like in in
psychology
and uh so so humans are very good at
understanding novel conceptual
combinations that come from just putting
together two concepts
um so you know if I if I if I tell you
about an apartment dog you wonder right
away what kind of dog I'm talking about
uh you will know first of all that it's
not uh an apartment with dog-like
features it's a dog that relates to
apartment in certain ways uh you will be
able to visualize that it's probably a
small dog because in an apartment
typically a dog needs to be on the small
size a small side uh you might be able
to infer values uh features of that kind
of dog based on uh the meaning of your
understanding of the two concepts
apartment and dog as well as some
background knowledge about apartments
and dogs
um
it's interestingly it's not it's not
totally syntax free uh because uh the
order in which you combine Concepts does
matter so for example a factory car is
not the same as a car factory
uh and you know a a factory car is a car
made in factories uh a car factory is
not a factory made in cars so there are
this subtle uh uh very complex a factory
car is a common in factories
a car factory is not effectively made in
cars it's the factory in which the cars
are made uh yeah and so uh there are
some interest there's some interesting
work in uh in in linguistic actually
trying to systematize the different ways
in which we combine nouns into phrasal
nouns like this it's actually complex uh
but my body is like this is not totally
syntax free because the order in which
you combine these nouns into phrasal
nouns actually matters to the way in
which we pause them
um
but it's not strictly compositional
because there's a lot of world
background World Knowledge that comes
into the interpretation of the
combination uh but anyway in this task
we we designed it with several sub tasks
and we decided to avoid precisely the
problem that you mentioned which is uh
that language you know deep learning
models tend to give use the lazy
relative they can and just latch onto
shallow heuristics uh to solve a given
problem so one of the ways went around
this is that we had some sub tasks that
choose only made up words that are
defined in the prompt so we just uh use
totally made up words uh and say uh you
know uh
a bean is a type of animal with four
legs and a bum is a is a type of of
dwelling uh
um what is a Bin ban uh and and well
actually we say which of the fourth
following sentences
uh is uh um uh the most uh um coherence
use of the concept being that and then
we have four sentences and one of the
sentences might be talking about dogs
going into dogs how you know dog houses
and dogs
for example
um but we also so we don't just use made
up words that the model the model has
never encountered we also use
distractors uh so for example here's a
for example if you take the concept of
combination burning questions
among the four sentences that the model
has to consider as that all use the the
phrase burning questions we included uh
sentences that uh like burning questions
are placing hearts or uh you know
burning questions on fire uh that you
know if the model was just latching on
to solid heuristics about Burning uh and
the contexts in which burning appears uh
you know that that might trick the model
into giving the wrong answer uh so could
I just like push on that tiny bit
because because you spoke about
apartment dog and apartment is something
that is grounded to things in its
training data and dog is something which
is grounded to things in its training
data and and then it combines them
together and I know you don't like
stitching and gluing but we'll use that
in in the the most generous way possible
but it it feels like it doesn't surprise
me that it has a competence at doing
that the the thing that it doesn't have
a competence at doing is things which
are not grounded either with the real
world or with things in in the training
data so for example I'm sure you've seen
um if you generate a daily image of
salmon
um in a in a river it shows you the
salmon from the supermarket swimming in
the river
right or if you ask it to generate a
woman on top of the world now on top of
the world means that she's feeling great
but it would probably just generate you
know like a woman on top of planet Earth
or something like that so do you see
what I mean it's these it's these hidden
meta relations that it's got no chance
of of
um understanding well I think that a few
things to say here first of all I don't
think anything that goes for language
models translates to Vision language
models and certainly not all of them so
Dolly too I've I've taken issue number
of claims that are made about
compositionality in deep learning
generally or even in text to image
models generally based on examples from
32 because it's trained with this
constructive constructive learning
objective that uh you know it looks at
these image caption Pairs and uh during
training it's it's fed but
um Pairs and image and captions that go
together and pairs that don't go
together and the the objective is to to
bring clothes together in the in the
latent space
um the vector representations of image
captions that actually go together and
further apart the ones that don't go
together and
they are I think pretty good reasons to
think that this kind of learning
objective will not get a model to induce
a lot of
information about syntactic structure of
language because
you can do that task uh without having
to to to to to to induce that
information just because first of all if
you look at the typical caption for an
image uh it does not include very
complex syntactic structure that involve
complex relations such as uh you know uh
there is uh uh like so for example even
even spatial relations so like there is
a a woman uh to the right of a wardrobe
the Wardrobe is uh uh to the you know to
the to the to the left of of a table and
things there just was just a picture of
a woman with a water around a table
um so already if you don't even have an
information in the caption that are
using the training data you you better
definition cannot cannot learn it uh and
then uh doing this contrastive learning
you can you can do that by just more or
less latching onto keywords instead of
uh so so you can have almost just a bag
of words approach to uh uh to the the
kind of linguistic description of an
image uh and that's mostly sufficient to
to discriminate between uh captions that
go and don't go with images
so so I'm not surprised that Dali 2
fails at uh say uh drawing a blue cube
onto the right Cube if you look at other
models like Parsi and other models that
use frozen uh pre-trained language
models as the text encoder instead of
creep
um they do much better at this kind of
thing so that's the first thing I would
say is I would be a little bit careful
about what you know looking at just what
Dali can cannot do
um
and then uh I don't even remember yeah
that the the women on top of the world I
mean um
you know humans as also need to learn
being on top of the world is is an idiom
right so humans uh need to learn what
that means uh uh if you talk to to a
child that has never encountered that
idiom about a person on top of the world
and ask them to throw that uh I'm pretty
sure they would draw someone on top of a
planet something like that uh so
I would argue that it is still an
analogy so on top of we we have a
natural
um sense of
um levels of happiness or levels of
status and being on top of something is
is definitely
um an analogy I I think it's something
which could be because the whole point
of a metaphor you know sort of using the
language from Douglas hofstata is it's
just a wonderful vehicle to kind of
convey understanding through you know
like he said the analogy making is the
kind of Interstate freeway of how our
brain works and I think I could say to
someone she's on top of the world and if
that person had never had that phrase
before she would understand what I meant
yeah I think that's a I mean that's an
interesting empirical question I'm not
so sure I mean I think it definitely is
the the idiom comes from some kind of
analogy or metaphor that's that's beyond
dispute
um
but I think that you just kind of
entered into common language and uh I
don't think when people learn that
expression or use it
uh they are actively thinking about the
analogy necessarily right so it just
becomes a way to say that someone is uh
very happy and a shorthand for that
um but uh even you know granting you
that point
you can uh I mean you can you can get
language models to to do various forms
of analogical reasoning it's it's
actually really remarkable uh the extent
to which you can do that I recently saw
uh someone posting an example with with
the new Bing chat that you know people
speculate might be a lot uh you know
more advanced model than than 2pt 3.5
who knows uh it does seem like it has
some more advanced capacities in some
respects and one thing that's fun to do
with being shot that this user was was
pointing out is that you can
um you can prompt it to do a comparison
table between two completely different
things that have nothing to do with to
do different it is that I'm not even at
the same level of abstraction or have
nothing to do with each other so that
particular example was uh make a table
uh uh comparing the the features or the
of the the specs of uh like a specific
Nokia phone and Jesus Christ and the
model generated this table that first of
all it's quite it's quite funny but it's
it's also quite witty in the way it's
it's during analysis so it's saying you
know
um
I I can't remember the detail but uh uh
every every line is is really an
instance of an analogy analogical
reasoning so there was one that was uh
indestructibility so the Nokia you know
three uh 3310 uh is known for being uh
really hard to to to to to break it was
a phone that was really sturdy uh
likewise Jesus Christ is uh you could
say is indestructible because uh you
know it was resurrected or uh the
resurrection beat as well there was a
line that was about you know the Nokia
3310 was brought back uh recently uh by
Nokia uh there was a new uh uh it was it
was it sold again so it's been
resurrected by Nokia Jesus Christ was
also never resurrected uh there was
something about display that talked
about the display of the Nokia and uh
what we know about potential physical
features of Jesus Christ uh and it goes
on and on and on and uh you know it's
very striking when you look at it and I
don't see how that's not an instance of
analogical reasoning of some form
yeah interesting and I suppose the the
criticism would be is it just selecting
um meta relations which have already
been created by humans or is it
genuinely creating new ones
so I I mean that's a that's a uh
something one could is it investigate by
uh looking up Nokia 310 Jesus Christ on
the internet I I mean who knows what
people have said on the internet but uh
this was just not not just in isolated
example then people uh tried the same
template with the most absurd uh and
absurdly upgraded Concepts uh and you
know it works very well uh so
I don't know I I my my hunch looking at
this is that uh it is it is latching on
two uh analogical and uh relationships
foreign
yeah it's it's like the the miracle that
humans have is we can take any two
objects I mean I I can kind of like pick
up a battery and I can pick up a can of
Coke and I can find a meta relation
between them right you know that they're
both grabbable although or they're both
you know solid or something like that
and there are an infinite number of
possible meta relations and we can we
can grab and select one and then through
the language game or whatever I
communicate it to you you can infer what
I mean and then it just kind of becomes
established in in language it's a
miracle how it works but um I wanted to
move on to simmer grinding a little bit
because I know you've got some things to
say about that and um Stephen harned
actually wrote this paper called the
symbol grounding problem I think several
decades ago and he said it's the problem
of how to make semantic interpretation
of a formal symbol system intrinsic to
the system rather than just parasitic on
the meaning in our heads and he spoke
about ungrounded symbols which are
manipulated by rules based on their
shape and grounded symbols which are
connected to things that they stand
through a causal chain of sensory
projections and and motor actions so
yeah why don't you kind of introduce the
symbol grounding problem and what do you
think about it yeah so so I think it's
interesting because as you say this this
uh this old problem uh has been
resurrected uh in uh in recent
discussions of language models uh but I
think the way in which people talk about
grounding when when it comes to language
models
um is somewhat obfuscated by uh the one
which different Notions of grounding
might be completed
uh so the the core notion of branding I
think is what I would call referential
grounding
um which is the idea that uh
many people talking about language
models are concerned with namely this
idea that their representations are
encodings of lexical items of words on
linguistic expressions
I'm not grounded in uh their reference
in the world because they don't have
direct access to the world but only have
access to uh linguistic information
so
um that's one notion of grounding it's
it's uh even before uh Hana Barbara
party the linguist had uh uh kind of
condored the phrase language to World
crowning to refer to this particular
notion
when we'll talk about grounding though
sometimes they mean something different
so sometimes I mean something like uh
what I would call sensory motor
grounding and I think Hana himself kind
of equivocates a little bit in two
things sensory motor grounding will be
uh connecting linguistic representations
to uh representations in other
modalities such as perceptual and motor
representations
um so this is what people have in mind
when they say that Vision language
models like Delhi 2 are grounded they
are grounded in the sense that they
encode linguistic and visual information
in the same Vector space and so in that
process the established connections
between uh initiative different
modalities
um but that doesn't mean they're
referentially grounded right that only
means they're grounded in that all the
sense which is sensory motor Grande
many people have argued for years that
all we need is multi-modality and we'll
speak about the multimodal language
model actually as well in a minute but
but Hana did basically say he
um I don't think he used the word
inactivism but he was basically saying
that you know if only we could have
robots who actually had physical
affordances in the real world then
suddenly the symbol grounding problem
wouldn't be an issue anymore but surely
there's so much more to it than that
just along the lines that we've been
speaking to
yeah I think that's that's true I mean
you just have to look at uh uh you know
old school classical uh robotic systems
or even CHR dlu uh in the blocks world
uh
you know you could argue again as I
mentioned earlier that the
representation of crtlu are grounded
referentially in the sense that
the symbols the linguistic symbols it
uses like red block are encode onto uh
are connected to representations of
virtual objects in the virtual blocks
world but it's that intrinsic running in
haunted sense right and I think that the
key point that Hana is concept with is
that these these grounding needs to be
intrinsic and not and not uh projected
onto these systems by symmetic
interpretation given by the programmers
um
but the other thing I would point out is
that you could have
so the the point about causal
interaction with the world
uh comes apart from the point about uh
multi-morality uh in the way that I
think that there is there is even a
double Association there so you can have
models like Dali 2 that are trained on
multimodal data so they're training text
and images but the trend on multimodal
data in the purely passive way because
they're just they just you know learn
like like all these transforming models
uh at training time from this uh stream
of of data that's sampling from the data
set uh in this purely passive way there
is no interaction there
um
vice versa you can imagine a system
that's purely linguistic
uh but that actually learns from
interaction uh with human for example
through dialogue so you can imagine the
language model that instead of being
trained passively through next word
prediction actually gets trained uh I
don't know what the learning objective
would be but uh you know would get
trained through that like would be very
impractical because uh you will probably
need uh many thousands of Euros for that
system to get any good and we just
output gibberish for uh the first
hundreds of years or something but
um you you could kind of uh conceptually
think of a system that that interacts
with uh the world in a pure in a purely
linguistic manner
um so so I think these two things do
compart but then grounding is also used
in other ways so people talk about you
know even in the in the in this in the
the the climbing towards a new paper
Emily bender and and uh Alex color talk
about uh running sometimes in ways that
relates to communicative intents so
some people talk about branding
linguistic representations in
communicative intent that's yet
something else right so you have a
system that might not have communicative
intent and yet has representations that
are refreshingly granted in the world
and or sensory motor uh be grounded in
in other models I think we'll get to
that in a minute when we speak about the
theory of Mind stuff yeah so so all of
these things I think are good to keep so
bright and yet other senses of grounding
I don't have to get into that but I um I
think the interesting point is that it's
not obvious entirely obvious to me that
even text only language models can't
achieve some very very limited form of
referential grounding this is why when I
mentioned earlier that you know
they have a pretty significant specific
significant form of inferential lexical
competence
um but they might also have some degree
of a referential lexical competence
um so
first of all you can think of certain
domains
that
might not require
a connection a direct connection to the
world in order to Grant linguistic
Expressions uh so one example would be
the very concept of a word
uh it might be just possible just by you
know being trained on Words uh or on
linguistic Expressions uh you can think
of the concept of a token or if you
don't want because of course language
models uh only see tokens not words and
and tokenization might be at the sub
Word level but just think of the concept
of a token then uh that's a concept
where you know you can you can you could
think well actually uh just living in
this text-only world is enough to uh uh
kind of have some form of referral
grounding of of your views of the of the
time token or you can you could take a
think of uh you know a certain logical
uh Concepts
um the concept of a conjunction uh thing
things like that
um
is debatable You could argue well
actually even these concepts are
grounded in some Kansas uh uh
interaction with the world in human uh
in humans but but I don't and I'm not
sure that would apply to all of this
sort of concept I think there are there
might be Concepts that uh can be
grounded in ethics yeah I can give you
many I mean I can look at event
semantics so this is something Walid
Sabbath says about these cognitive
templates that are not grounded in the
physical Universe they would they would
still exist even if the universe didn't
exist like located
um at or contains in
these things are not grounded in
physical reality yeah so I mean some
some psychologists would say well there
are ground they are related to more
concrete Concepts that are grounded and
they are just obstructed away from uh
these Concepts but they are indirectly
running in this way
but
you know that's interesting because if
you if you go on that route then that
brings me to my second point which is
how is to say that the text only
language models are not don't also have
some uh representations that are
indirectly grounded uh through the
mediation of language uh into uh uh the
interactions with the world that humans
hide in order to produce the text on
which they're trained so uh the the
training data of these large genomics
models encodes a lot of implicit
structure
about the world that is reflected in the
structure of language and this is
actually provable there are some there's
some really uh great work by alipavlik
for example looking at uh and her
colleagues looking at
um the fact that you can you can find
isomorphisms between representations of
color concepts in language models and uh
actual the actual structure of the color
space
like Sierra about different different uh
ways to represent uh color space and
relationship between colors so you can
map one to the other yeah uh but but
that isn't that that's um phenomenology
and is is that not orthogonal to what
goes on in a language model
uh well I mean what do you mean so I
mean you you could conceivably think
that language models can induce a lot of
information about experience just by
being trained a lot of text that talks
about experience right so it's not uh
that baffling to me that it would just
learn uh certain structural properties
of uh
experience Human Experience yeah well
you know we spoke earlier about those
different categories and and there's the
kind of I guess that would be
ontologically subjective and that to me
is is the category which is just
divorced from language models I can't
understand how it could possibly learn
anything about that but what do you
think
so there are I think it's um is it there
are two papers that look at column
spaces
um you have some representations of
color spaces that are not
um perceptually uh accurate so there are
ways you know uh like standard color
spaces that are used uh uh for clock you
know for for color grading or uh
um might not actually reflect exactly
the way in which humans perceive colors
so uh
the their
color representation of language models
are grounded in that uh
that you know wouldn't necessarily
entail anything about uh inducing
information about you know the the kind
of structure uh those experiential space
of human Human Experience uh but there
is one paper that looks as clap
specifically which I think is a
perceptually accurate uh color space
could could it be that we've almost got
the causation the wrong way round I mean
if if that is the case then maybe and
I'm sure they've done studies on this
the way we perceive color
might be determined by the you know the
the concepts the symbols the the reality
and and so on so so it's that level of
directionality
yeah I think there is uh pretty good
evidence that that's not the case so the
whole sepia worth half of this about you
know language heavily influencing the
way in which we perceive the world uh it
has been mostly discredited uh if you
look at cross-cultural evidence
so so I I I don't think that's a
straightforward uh Nation but but here
is another piece of evidence so not
about experience but about these
isomorphisms that I'm interested in so
there's another paper that showed that
uh I think it's called The Language
models know the way to run and it's
looking at uh whether language models uh
you know their uh encodings of of uh
spatial uh well well location words like
uh specifically looking at uh names of
cities like Rome Paris London and so on
is isomorphic to the actual spatial
relationships Within These cities and
they do find this isomorphism uh so
that's also interesting it suggests that
you know they can actually induce uh
meaningful information about the
structure of the real world uh that is
uh reflected in the structure of the
Corpus because the Corpus is produced by
humans who interact with the world world
but but that that's saying something
very deep because you you were speaking
about Firth and the distributional
hypothesis um earlier and there's
actually studies in humans with the
medial temporal lobe that if you if you
show them images together in a certain
order then there's a topology which is
formed in the brain which represents the
the kind of the the structure of how you
showed them the information but this is
all pointing to there are many different
paths to a form you know to form a
representation
you know we're naturally skeptical of
the distributional hypothesis right
because it's analogous to what you were
saying earlier that large language
models they just predict the next token
and the next token but then you just
gave an example with with um
phenomenology that what what actually
emerges in the brain is is something
which is you know almost exactly as as
we would expect it to and it seems
completely counter-intuitive to us that
using this very like naive way of of
constructing this topology would
actually produce the right
representation but it does yeah so I
would I wouldn't say that
um I would say that distributional
semantics is definitely uh an important
part of the semantics of words uh so
um I would just say that it's not it you
know it's not the whole it's not the
whole story uh that
[Music]
um
again think of it more in terms of the
kind of competence that we need to
understand word meaning I think we need
both inferential and referential
competence so we need above the ability
to uh relate words together in ways that
support material inference uh that's the
inferential bit
and that's the one that language models
are pretty good at but we also need to
be able to name things in the world
respond to instructions to you know do
things as well which by the way there is
worked by um uh Google AI for example uh
the seikan series of papers where they
plug language models onto robots that
can actually do things in the world
um
and so that's another piece of evidence
that's interesting to discuss and
there's also uh this uh
you know various papers about world
models in in language models and one of
the recent one that caught my attention
is one of the the
GPT model trend on the Othello game I
don't know if you came across that uh
paper oh no so it's a gbd model that's
strange from scratch only on linguistic
descriptions of moves in the game of
fellow
which is such that
um uh you know just in terms of
combinational possibilities it would be
completely impossible for
a language model to learn how to play
Othello just by Brick memorization and
what's interesting is that after
training the model is actually able to
uh
predict uh closable next moves for any
given state of the game
which again is very hard to explain in
terms of root memorization uh it's
pretty much absurd but also you can
change the internet representation of
the model to change the predicted move
to a different move
and that's and there is ongoing
follow-up work now to use tools for
mechanistic interpretability to actually
look at the attention heads and see
whether we can reverse engineer the
computations that are induced by this
model to predict Othello moves
um but but that's another piece of
evidence that's interesting that
suggests that language models can
actually learn a world model at least in
this very simple type game cases
um
that uh you know is goes as much Beyond
just uh this uh basic idea of next token
prediction uh as just being able to
complete right
but but it comes back to this notion of
what does it mean to understand you know
it's like um that uh was it the fourth
game with alphago where
um it's it just produced a train of
terrible moves because it got into a
delusional State it's what Christopher
Summerfield calls the uh swiss cheese
phenomenon where you know sometimes
you're in a hole in the Swiss cheese and
it goes completely bananas and it starts
hallucinating and going crazy and um and
it's a similar thing with this example
you just gave you can also get chat GPT
to play chess and it doesn't have an
abstract model of Chess so Gary Marcus
would say well if it doesn't have an
abstract model of the world then it's
not a world model at all but of course
it it is a world model but it's it's a
very kind of like
I don't know whether you'd call it a
high resolution or a low resolution
model but it's a it's a it's a surface
model
um of of the world so tragicidity is
terrible at chess
um
uh actually the Bing chat is pretty good
at chess so there's recent uh uh really
yeah yeah yeah it can uh it uh there is
there's recent uh experiments showing
that it it can output just based on a
sequence of moves uh
um legal moves in the vast majority of
cases and it can actually play a decent
game of chess but the problem is with
this is that it's harder to control for
memorization even though again the
combinations are so uh crazed potential
combinations and potential states of a
game of the game of chess so so a crazy
uh uh high that uh numerous that it's
it's difficult to see how it could do
this with just Brute Force memorization
but the thing that's nice about the
official GPT paper is that's really
training the model from scratch
only on on autilla moves and of course
the model never has any access to the
actual uh board game of Othello and
what's interesting is that the the
researcher Kenneth Lee who uh I think
was uh Kenneth who did that work
um looked at also the uh internal
representations of the model and showed
that you can actually reconstitute
um the topology of a game of Othello of
a book of the board uh by projecting uh
internet representations which is kind
of wild
um but yeah again there's there's
something going on here that's more than
than just focusing on the next token and
I think mechanistic interoperability is
the key to to get at that
I wanted to talk about theory of mind
with you Raphael because you're you're
probably out of all of the people in the
world that I could speak to you're
probably the best person to speak to
about this but yeah so language models
are powerful tools for natural language
processing uh but they're often treated
as black boxes that generate or process
text without understanding their meaning
or purpose as we've just been discussing
and um so this theory of Mind thing is
quite interesting here because we treat
language models we could treat them as
agents which can infer and manipulate
the mental states of other agents in the
world reasoning about their goals and
beliefs and and actions and um there's
an interesting paper I read yesterday
actually called computational language
acquisition with theory of Mind from
Andy louetto I'm not sure if you've
spoken about that but that they built a
model which used an internal listener to
simulate how a teacher would interpret
its utterances and and an internal
teacher model to infer the teachers
goals and intentions and I've looked up
a little bit around on this and there
seems to be three approaches for
modeling theory of mind there's false
belief tasks pragmatic models and these
internal listener models so that that's
kind of like my perspective on on this
but
um give give us your take on on how we
can build models with a theory of mind
which is to say to reason about the
beliefs and intentions of others yes
that's uh that's a Hot Topic right now
uh can language models develop uh some
kind of a theory of Minds
um I haven't read this you just
mentioned I've seen it pop up actually
um I haven't heard it yet but
I think it's generally quite hard to
conclusively uh
establish that language models have
induced something like a theory of mind
uh because if you just uh
true if you just test it and start that
theory of mine tests the things that we
might use
with animals it's really hard to rule
out
um but obviously linguistic versions of
this of these tasks it's really hard to
rule out that the model is not just
solving this based on other statistical
patterns that really don't involve uh
any inferences about the mental states
of of an agent
there is this interesting preprint by uh
Jacob Andrus called language models as
agent models that makes a pretty strong
claim uh namely that uh
you know we know that uh language models
have this remarkable ability to uh
kind of and body uh uh values pushy
possible agents in the way this this
peak in the way they generate text
actually this is why in this in this
piece I published last summer in
Nautilus I I said that it's maybe Market
to call them stochastic chameleons than
stochastic parrots
um and uh but
so so uh uh Jacob kind of Builds on that
idea and say well uh really what's
happening there when you uh prompt the
model
is that it's gonna settle on uh the
simulation of a particular agent in the
way in which you will generate answers
uh a particular agent with particular
beliefs and goals so for example uh you
know if you tell it's you are an expert
uh
um I don't know like uh uh bird
scientists and you know every fact there
is about birds and then you ask a
question about birds it will tend to
give factually accurate answers uh
because you've prompted it in that way
and it can do through you know through
in context learning it can it can it can
which by the way is has been shown to be
equivalent to a virtual form of fine
tuning uh you could see that as being uh
on Jacob zoo is that you you could see
that as as her kind of uh zooming in on
on perhaps a specific part of latent
space Source uh that then that is
equivalent to simulating an agent uh
that he's an expert bird watcher or
something along these lines with certain
background beliefs and knowledge and
goals
um
so I actually had an extension about
this with with Jacob but I
I I'm skeptical that you can Grizzly
establish this uh because there is there
isn't much
uh more deflationary hypothesis which is
simply that uh what you can do by
prompting the model through this in
context learning is just uh uh get the
model to
um
uh essentially mimic the style and uh
you know linguistic quirks of uh uh
particular agent whose outputs was
reflected in the training data
um but there is uh there's a lot of
daylight between that claim and the
claim that they're literally simulating
agents with goals beliefs and desires
and background knowledge so think of the
stylistic case so if we prime a model if
you prompt a model to
write in the style of Jane Austen
you know even vanilla gp3 is very good
at that it will output paragraphs and
sell it to Austin
um I think it'll be quite strange to say
that it's simulating Jane Austen not you
know the stimulating being the agent
Jane Austen with Jane Austen's uh
background I believe stars and so on and
and ideas about literature and style
um is doing something that seems much
simpler than that and I think the same
can be applied to other examples so a
recent case was the the whole Fiasco
runs being shot in Sydney uh where
people figure out that uh you know the
the original version of Bing sad uh if
you if you prompted it in a certain way
uh had this uh uh you know weird
antagonistic Behavior that's actually
not that weird when you look at this
transcript so if you look at the Kevin
Ruth's piece and the transcripts there's
a lot of leading uh prompts and priming
in the prompts that uh you know bring up
jungian ideas about this this the dark
self and so on and that obviously primed
uh the model to act out as uh as this
kind of fictional character
um was it simulating uh
the Sydney the dark double of of uh the
goods being shot uh I don't think so I
think it's just uh engaging in this kind
of creative fiction exercise that uh can
be analyzed in terms of uh you know
statistical patterns for the kind of
language user on English community that
you've primed it to emulate uh that's
not quite the same as literally
simulating mental States like beliefs
desires and
back on cash
I mean I read that article on less Wrong
by Janus you know about simulators and I
do actually quite love this idea that
language models have agentiveness and
there's a kind of simulator and a
simulacrimp and and it can embody uh
many different um people at the same
time
but I guess I was going to ask you um I
mean how does the theory of Mind relate
to other cognitive abilities in in
language models I mean you know we've
been teasing apart uh by the way
Shanahan spoke about the the intentional
stance when I spoke with floridi he's
actually amazing he's invented this
philosophy of information he gave me an
example of a Michelangelo you know like
a um someone in the street can paint it
on on the concrete but it's not it's not
a Michelangelo you know it might have
the same aesthetic might have the same
technique but you know you've got all of
these other things you've got the the
subjective experience you've got the
intention you've got the purpose you've
got the the semantics you've got so much
stuff there and it's the same thing with
theory of mind to a certain extent so we
could just argue oh well um if you if
you just scale up the model size and the
data quality and change the fine tuning
and the pre-training objectives then all
of a sudden this thing will emerge but
to me it fundamentally feels like a
little bit extra and and also I'm
interested I mean you would as you just
said symbol grounding is required for
natural language understanding but
surely a theory of Mind should be
requisite for things like common sense
and you know reasoning and causal
inference and counterfactual thinking
and even meta learning
um it feels it feels very important but
I have this fundamental question of can
it even exist
yeah so I'm not totally convinced that
theory of mine is needed for some of the
things you mentioned like Common Sense
reasoning you you can reason about what
happens when I push a ball off a table
without being able to uh
wrote inferences about the mental states
of other agents I think but um
so so to kind of conceptualize how
theory of Mind relates to two issues
about language
um
it basically relates to this whole other
aspects of language years which is
pragmatics and uh
um the kind of gracian tradition uh in
uh Linguistics looking at uh the ways in
which we interpret the meaning of
expressions of utterances in
conversation uh that go beyond simply
parsing the strict linguistic meaning of
a sentence uh regardless of the context
in which is uttered but also draw about
extra linguistic information and
inferences including inferences about
what uh the other languages are where
the person are talking to is trying to
convey and Grace delineated various
principles that seem to apply to
communication
and the way in which it works in humans
adapts some non-human animals is that it
seems that we are trying to uh uh
triangulate on a common ground in the
way we understand terms in communication
in ways that involves first of all
having an intent to communicate when
self-communicated intents and modeling
the other uh persons in them to
communicate with oneself but in fact
a crisis in pragmatics
goes all the way to uh something like
third degree theory of Mind where either
inference is about uh what I think that
you think that I want to communicate so
it is kind of really complex uh higher
order uh inferences about mental States
on a side note there is actually I I was
at this uh psychology and philosophy
meeting last summer and there was this
interesting poster about
um these experiments on on Alex the
great parrots which is a famous uh uh
animal subject
in animal cognition that is great parrot
called Alex that was tested on its
ability to engage in various forms of
linguistic Behavior Uh because of course
parrots can uh utter words uh and uh
what's uh what's ironic is that parrots
are extremely intelligent creatures uh
such that the stochastic Parts uh
analogy is perhaps not the the insult or
the inflationary claim that it's meant
to be uh and what was interesting to
this poster was was suggesting that
perhaps Alex the great parrot had
some even some some a form of uh third
degree theory of mind uh and and had
communicative intent because there is
this one episode where
um the Alex wanted well that's an
interpretation but
was presented with fruits that uh he
wasn't particularly happy to eat so the
fruits that it was able to name was uh
bananas and and berries I think
um and uh
there was this whole interaction where
the parrot was was gesturing at an apple
and started calling it up
I don't want to put too much
interpretation on the case but started
at least uttering uh uh paneri which is
a combination of banana and Berry right
uh uh and uh repeatedly saying binary
until uh he was brought the apple and
then ate the apple and stopped saying
binary and so oh so Emily was right then
it was just stitching and gluing well I
mean this is very you know if you want
to really interpret this as an intent to
communicate uh
the desire to eat the apple by counting
a new word uh
that's uh that's really really
sophisticated uh and uh you know that's
uh definitely inside parrots being way
more sophisticated uh language users
than uh they've given uh credit for in
this traditional sarcastic Parts piece
indeed